-JoJo, you are up next.
Let's see what challenge
you get, buddy.
You're always down
for a challenge.
-I'm always down
-Yeah, I know.
-This is so iconic.
Oh, my God.
I feel so cool.
-You are so cool.
-Thank you.
♪♪
-Wheel of Musical Impressions.
-You got this.
-♪ Wheel of
Musical Impressions ♪
♪ Spin the wheel of
musical impressions ♪
-Oh, my God.
I'm terrified.
-You already know
how this one works.
You get an artist and you're
going to have to sing a song
while doing
an impression of them.
Let's see what you get.
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh! I can't look!
-Bohemian --
-No way.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you have -- I don't know.
How are you going to do this?
-No way.
-"Bohemian Rhapsody"
by Queen as Eminem.
-Oh, my God.
-Jam Band...
-Yes.
-Can you give us a beat?
-We got this.
-I can't wait to see this.
♪♪
♪ Is this the real life? ♪
♪ Is this just fantasy? ♪
♪ Caught in a landside ♪
♪ No escape from reality ♪
♪ Open your eyes ♪
♪ Look up to the skies and see ♪
♪ I'm just a poor boy,
I need no sympathy ♪
♪ Too late, my time has come ♪
♪ Sends shivers down my spine,
body's aching all the time ♪
♪ Goodbye, everybody,
I've got to go ♪
♪ Gotta leave you all behind
and face the truth ♪
♪ Mama, oooh, I see a little
silhouetto of a man ♪
♪ Scaramouch, Scaramouch,
will you do the Fandango? ♪
♪ Thunderbolts and lightning,
very, very frightening me ♪
♪ Galileo, Figaro,
magnifico ♪
♪ I'm just a poor boy,
nobody loves me ♪
♪ He's just a poor boy
from a poor family ♪
♪ Spare him his life
from this monstrosity ♪
♪ Easy come, easy go,
will you let me go ♪
will you let me go? ♪
♪ No, no, no, no, no, no, no ♪
♪ Mama mia, mama mia, mama mia,
let me go ♪
♪ So you think you can stop me
and spit in my eye ♪
♪ So you think you can love me
and leave me to die ♪
♪ So you think you can stop me
and spit in my eye ♪
♪ So you think you can love me
and leave me to die ♪
♪ Easy come, easy go,
little high, little low ♪
♪ Any way the wind blows ♪
♪ Uh-oh, Galileo, Galileo,
Figaro, magnifico ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Is this the real life,
is this just a fantasy ♪
Caught in a landside,
no escape from reality
Open your eyes, look up
to the skies and see
I'm just a poor boy,
I need no sympathy
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Like that?
-Girl, who are you?
What did you just become?
-Where did that come from?
-Yes, JoJo!
-Wowzers. That was phenomenal.
-Thank you!
-JoJo Siwa.